raymond théodose bonjour bonjour
monsieur livory alors vous avez 64 ans
vous êtes retraité des banques vous êtes
maire de rivière pilote depuis 2014
vous êtes candidat à votre succession
vous allez conduire la liste de la
dynamique pilotine c'est bien cela tout
à fait alors pourquoi vous y allez
raymond tillaud 2 et bien je depuis
avril 2014 je suis donc à la tête de la
vie rivière-pilote nous avons commencé
avec mon équipe
un certain nombre de projets et j'en ai
projet qui il faut quand même connu au
moins plus d'une mandature donc c'est
pour ça qu'à sion que je voulais au
moins terminer ses projets et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je me représente de
nouveau pour les des suffrages en mars
2010 il y a quatre candidats issus du
mime c'est une grande première vous êtes
aussi issu du mime à une grande première
à rivière pilote en créole duke a dit
que les chats tlapa laraque à bâle
depuis le départ d' alfred marie-jeanne
c'est la débandade
non je ne parle pas de limonade 1 j'ai
plutôt envie de parler de démocratie de
du maire actuel
ça veut dire que j'estime que nous
sommes en démocratie
toutes les personnes ont le droit de se
présenter donc je ne peux pas parler de
dépendance mais monte aux deux youtube
et marie jeanne n'est pas des cabines
c'est vrai que dans ce temps du temps où
alfred marie jeanne était meilleur du
ridja pilote il n'y avait pas beaucoup
de candidats
est ce une peur je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas je crois que depuis que je suis
arrivé il y a
j'ai envie de dire que là il ya une
liberté d'expression et une certaine
sérénité
les gens peuvent s'exprimer sans peur
est ce que vous êtes et ce que vous vous
attendiez également l'adoubement
le soutien d' alfred marie jeanne non je
note le soutien je n'attends que le
soutien du peuple
d'autant plus que je n'existe pas par
moi même donc j'ai toujours dit que il y
a deux hommes alfred marie-jeanne
fissures kareo à la tête de la
productivité et territoriales et moi je
fais mon travail
à rivière-pilote pour les administrés du
on dit qu'il ne veut pas se présenter
pas ne veut pas se prononcer pardon pour
ne pas vous gêner
par contre c'est une question qu'il
faudra du coup je ne sais pas il s'est
quand même prononcé et dernièrement j'ai
entendu qu'il soutient le fils de
l'ancien maire mais à mon sens la
déverser sa bile a dit me lever c'est
bien ça mais je crois que nous allons
mener normalement notre campagne et ils
se sont en tout état de cause les
électeurs de rivière pilote qui vont
faire la décision avant de passer au
programme et à vos projets comment vous
percevez la présence de denis lui régis
qui membres de pays à pays à ce qu'on
présente présidée par jean philippe
miller jean philippe ries lors que vous
avez toujours soutenu la la j'ai envie
de dire mystère et boule de gomme mais
comme comme les toutes les personnes en
ont le droit d'être présente donc je ne
sais pas comment qualifier cette
candidature mais en tout comme jeudi le
peuple bolivien pilotes et souverain des
candidatures non je ne suis déçu de rien
du tout puisque vous et dégage son camp
démocrate donc tout le monde a l'air
d'être candidat donc je n'ai pas de
déception particulière c'est dans les
une que les piloter vont se prononcer
alors quelles sont les grandes lignes de
votre programme quels sont les projets
qu'ils vous restent encore à mener que
vous pouvez mener alors c'est vraiment
vraiment ce projet qui me tient à coeur
donc le le papy le programme d'action en
pagne nation qu'on va continuer qui déjà
à un état très très très avancé et puis
au niveau au niveau de la de la mairie
c'est surtout un projet que je compte
mener au niveau de la halle de la mairie
quand il y à des inondations nous il ya
une certaine une certaine angoisse donc
je voulais quand même sécurisé et faire
en sorte que au sein de cette mandature
je puisse quand même construit une
mairie quitte à garder quand même là
l'ancienne mairie avec des avec des
bureaux annexes et aussi créer un auteur
un pôle médical éventuellement avec deux
laboratoires parce qu'il y en a un grand
besoin les pilotes et aussi des
établissements financiers parce qu'il ya
des gens qui souhaitent revenir sur les
pilotes
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya une certaine
crainte de la montée des eaux
très bien on dit que les commerçants de
rivière pilote sont mécontents de leur
situation qu à chaque inondation ils
sont victimes et et qu' ils se sentent
parfois abandonnées non mais je crois
que c'est une mauvaise interprétation
effectivement dernièrement les
commerçants de rivière-pilote était venu
me voir mais pour à côté du maire porte
encore plus fort pour que nous puissions
être entendu parce que n'oubliez pas que
la larivière les vivian puisque nous
avons lagon de la petite c'est du
ressort de l'état donc c'est passé par
la ville mais je m'applique à côté des
pilotes 1 et des commerçants au
quotidien c'est pour leur permettent
quand même de d'avoir une certaine
amélioration et c'est ce que j'ai
toujours fait donc concernant je voulais
aussi dire que par rapport à l'autre
continuer la réduction de la lame d'eau
et puis un quelque chose qui me venu
puisque dernièrement il ya eu des
inondations cdd des portes anti
inondations et la ville va s'impliquer
vraiment peu ledent dans ce projet pour
permettre vraiment aux administrés et
aux commerçants d'être pierre raymond
théodose je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
[Musique]